Uh we now uh have uh Christelle Magnol
senior consultant at the semantic
partner partners also lead ontologists
for the IKEA knowledge graph. So today
uh um Christelle is going to share the
journey of implementing the IKEA
knowledge graph across a decentralized
uh franchise system tackling challenges
like data governance and onboarding. Uh
so please join me in welcoming uh
Christella.
>> Thank you. Uh can you hear me? Is it is
the mic working?
>> Yes.
So um as Amy just mentioned I'm Christy.
I'm the lead on the IKEA knowledge
graph. I was going to present today with
my colleague Andreas Tolson but
unfortunately couldn't make it today. So
um it's just me. Um and I'm going to
talk to you about the IKEA knowledge as
a service.
Um,
I've got a small graph here to help you
uh understand where the team where our
team fits within uh the IKEA retail
business. Um, as you can see, so I'm I'm
I'm a I'm a consultant. I'm hired by um
Inter IKEA systems. Um, and there is the
digital product owner uh of the on the
IK on the IK team, the IKEA knowledge
graph team. um which is the team that is
developing uh our knowledge graph. It's
part of intera systems which is part of
inter I group and I'm going to talk to
you a little bit about intera group in a
moment and the uh holding company is
intera holding
and today I'm going to talk to you um
I'm going to give you some context
around the uh IKEA know and I'm going to
talk to you about intera group then I'm
going to tell you uh about the how how
the IKEA knowledge graph started and and
finally I'll tell you about our vision
for uh the future of our knowledge graph
and there will be time at the end for
for questions.
So the IKEA uh the intera group um what
is it? Um IKEA uh is a brand and uh at
IKEA they like to do things differently
because it keeps the brand uh fresh and
exciting and it's a brand that unites
thousands of co-workers and hundreds of
companies with different owners all
around the world. So, it's one brand,
but it's it's a lot of people and it's a
lot of companies.
And um in the 1980s the uh IKEA business
was growing was expanding and its
founder uh Ingvar Campred realized that
he needed to protect the IKEA concept
and he uh decided that the best way to
do so was to use a franchise system
because it would uh allow for
international expansion while protecting
the underlying concept and it would also
u allow for it would also promote
entrepreneurship. ship. So IKEA uh Inter
IKEA system uh systems that I mentioned
earlier, they're the franchiser. They're
the worldwide worldwide franchiser and
they um they own the concept. They
continuously uh develop the IKEA concept
and they make sure that it's uh it's
implemented across uh the franchise.
The IKEA franchises are companies that
pay a franchise fee and they're the ones
who um uh meet the customers. They're
the ones who sell to the customers
and they uh they are responsible for um
creating highquality customer
experiences for IKEA customers.
And this franchise system is uh people
oriented uh and it it encourages
everybody to to work together to
contribute
uh and uh there's a value at IKEA which
is togetherness. It's one of the key
values at IKEA. Uh this idea of all
everybody working together and everybody
contributing and that's something that
is reflected uh in in our how we manage
our knowledge graph in our vision for
the knowledge graph which I'm going to
um show you later.
This is a a simplified diagram of uh the
IKEA franchise system and value chain.
So you can see on the left here um the
inter IKEA group which is a group of um
companies it includes inter IKEA systems
the franchiser.
It also includes other companies like
IKEA of Sweden who are responsible for
designing and developing the product
range the the IKEA product range.
There's also IKEA marketing and
communications. It's again another
company a separate company obviously
responsible for marketing and
communications. Uh there's also
companies like uh um IKEA supply again a
separate company responsible for uh
managing purchasing and distribution.
And then we have the IKEA franchises.
Um, and at at the top here you can see
the Inca group. It's the largest
franchisee.
Uh, it operates on 31 markets and
there's a lot of other franchises across
the world. And through that franchise
system, uh, the IKEA retail business
operates on, uh, 62 markets.
Um
so I gave you u some context uh around
how um the context around the um the
IKEA knowledge graph. Um and so how why
did it start? Why why do we have an IKEA
knowledge graph? Uh the founder uh Adam
Kerv
um started as an interior designer in
one of the shops in Japan uh before
moving on to customer experience design.
And as a customer experience designer,
he was frustrated by his lack of access
to data to the data that he needed to
create uh new solutions for uh to
improve customer experience.
And the reason for that is that a lot of
that data was uh inaccessible because it
was uh uh siloed. It was very much
siloed due to the nature of the
franchise. As I mentioned earlier, lots
of companies with different owners. They
don't always communicate well together.
They don't necessarily share their data.
You would imagine they would, but but
they don't. They operate quite
independent independently.
Um so that's one of the barriers to uh
access to uh data. Another barrier is
that a lot of the uh IKEA expertise and
knowhow is actually stored documented in
uh um documents like PowerPoint slides
which are not easily retrievable not
easily accessible
uh or searchable
and even uh a lot of the knowhow a lot
of uh that unique IKEA knowhow is
actually in in the coworker's heads in
in the interior in the heads of the
interior designers and other co-workers
who uh develop their expertise over
years if not decades. Um but it's not
necessarily actually documented
anywhere. So that's why it's difficult
to access um the data digitally.
So um um actually going back uh Adam had
this idea of uh uh using a knowledge
graph to uh break the silos and to uh to
develop a common vocabulary across the
IKEA value chain uh to and to uh to
promote data sharing across the various
companies. He was later join joined by
Katarina Carrie who was the lead
ontologist on the IKG team who's was
here um uh at the conference. Um and she
was the lead ontologist until last
August and she led the team that was
responsible for translating uh the IKEA
expertise um uh decades of IKEA
expertise into uh a knowledge graph
and it started with really a proof of
concept um around online customer
recommendation. So um the aim of uh the
knowledge graph was both to um imp to
create solutions for customers like
product recommendations
uh high quality product recommendations
but also to uh automate and streamline
um existing processes internal uh
processes so for the co for the
co-workers but it's the proof of concept
was was customerf facing and was around
um customer recommendations on the site.
Um, in IKEA stores, interior designers
can display uh, for example, a sofa with
uh, throws and cushions and and other
articles to show to the customers how
they can uh, complement uh, the sofa if
if they're looking for a sofa. So, to
inspire customers to buy more articles
to complement their main purchase.
Um
and uh when IKEA tried to replicate that
on the website, uh it became complicated
because a lot of uh um connections
between products had to be had to be
created man manually had to be added
manually by co-workers which of course
was not scalable. They couldn't do it
fast enough and efficiently enough.
So the idea was to use a knowledge
graph, the IKEA knowledge graph and uh
its reasoning uh capability to scale
this and uh not only to scale this but
also to capture all that expertise um
that that was in in in the co-workers
heads in the interior designers heads in
their experience and to capture it
inside the knowledge graph and and and
use that to offer really high quality uh
product recommendation. on the website
which is something that machine learning
solutions are often not very very good
at actually.
So you can see here uh on the website uh
someone is interested in buying a
cushion cover and the website recommends
uh a cushion pad that has the correct
dimensions and that uh you will need to
to uh complete your purchase. Um so
there are two types of recommendations.
There were two types of recommendations
for that proof of concept. Uh products
that complete a purchase. So that's for
instance if you buy uh if you buy a lamp
the website will say you will need to
you will need some bulbs with that lamp
or if you buy a cushion cover you will
need a cushion pad. And there are also
products that uh complement your
purchase such as u a throw for example
on a sofa.
And uh with this use case of the cushion
covers um and and and cushion pads, I
here was able to measure a three-digit
increase percentage uh in online sales
for um for cushion pads for for cushion
pads and that we could link it to the uh
reasoning capability of of the knowledge
graph. So the proof of concept was uh
was successful and uh uh we could prove
the value of the knowledge graph in uh
increasing sales.
So now that uh we have demonstrated that
value, we have embarked on a a new
journey which is uh transitioning from
um the IKEA knowledge graph as a product
to uh the IKEA knowledge graph as a
platform and to uh in order to scale um
the knowledge graph across the whole of
the IKEA uh franchise system that I
described earlier. So what do I mean by
uh product versus platform? Until now uh
a core team, the team that worked on
this proof of concept uh was um a
relatively small team uh was building
the knowledge graph um on on their own
and now and other teams could use the
results uh from that that from that
knowledge graph. uh but now we want to
offer the knowledge truck as a platform
to uh decentralize teams and
organization across IKEA so that they
can themselves develop uh domain
ontologies and domain graphs and
contribute to the expansion of the
graph.
So transitioning uh from product to
platform uh means that we're opening up
the knowledge of capabilities to uh
diverse teams across um diverse teams
and organizations across uh the IKEA
franchise. Uh because we want to enable
them to really leverage this powerful
tool to uh to innovate in ways that we
may may even um may not have even
imagined yet.
uh and we want to go be beyond uh
customerf facing solutions like the one
I showed with the PC uh and and we want
those teams to also develop solutions
that will benefit co-workers IKEA
co-workers
um and in fact we've started on boarding
teams already who uh work in various
domains we we've onboarded decentralized
teams uh who are developing solutions
for instance uh in domains like um
content management, uh digital asset
management and even uh conversational uh
conversational AI um so chat bots for
for co-workers
and the uh the idea uh really the
ultimately the aim is to connect all the
data across the IKEA value chain um via
the knowledge graph from the initial
product design idea to uh manufacturing
the product to uh supply chain logistics
to the customer meeting points, the
points of sale like the website or the
stores or other digital channels.
Uh and by adopting a platform approach
really we're not we're not replacing
existing systems or processes. We are uh
providing this tool so that the teams uh
can uh enhance their current uh
operations.
And this approach uh is crucial crucial
for scaling uh the knowledge tra
capabilities across IKEA because the
reality is the the the original team is
too small to to cater for all uh use
cases. Um we couldn't we couldn't do it
all on our own. There are so many
domains within IKEA. Um so by empowering
individual teams decentralized teams we
are uh on the one on the one hand uh
really able to tap into their very
unique expertise uh their very specific
expertise domain expertise uh but we're
also enabling them to uh develop
solutions that will um that will meet
their their their specific needs. So
they're they're best placed really to to
decide how to use the knowledge and what
solutions to develop and what problems
to solve with it.
So through this distributed approach,
we're hoping to uh um improve data
connectivity across the franchise and uh
really um uh improve efficiency and and
improve um decision making at all
levels.
But of course there are challenges and
the first challenge is communication.
So as we expand the knowledge raft um
it's um we're having to talk to very
diverse teams as I mentioned uh with
very varied uh levels of expertise and
knowledge graphs are are very technical
systems um and we're talking to
stakeholders who may not have uh any
background in in technology and actually
don't know what a knowledge graph is um
let alone an ontology. So our first uh
task is to demystify knowledge graphs to
to make knowledge draft knowledge graphs
understand accessible and understandable
to to all of our stakeholders and that
requires uh clear communication
communication that is jargon free
and also a focus on practical benefits
and uh and practical applications of the
technology.
Uh what is very useful as well when when
we talk to stakeholders is to uh uh show
them examples of concrete real world
examples of knowledge tra knowledge
graphs and how they are being used uh in
various domains like uh medical research
or finance or even the job market. So
for example, I like to I like to tell
them about the uh LinkedIn knowledge
graph and I can how it can be used to
link people with their skills uh to
companies and job offerings uh job job
openings and and that's something that
people can understand if they don't know
what the knowledge graph is. It becomes
very concrete in their minds and they
can understand uh more clearly what you
can do with a knowledge graph. So so
very concrete examples is one a good way
to uh demystify knowledge graphs.
The second uh challenge is governance.
Uh and it's actually a major challenge.
It's it's a very very big challenge and
you can imagine in a franchise system
like the IKEA franchise system with all
its various companies uh you can imagine
um that it would be a big challenge.
So we want to have uh we want we need to
establish clear rules and guidelines uh
around data ownership, access rights and
quality control. And we must ensure um
um data integrity and compliance with
all the relevant uh data protection
requirements.
And it's a very delicate balance between
maintaining control um maintaining
centralized control. So the c the core
team having control over what's being
developed
uh for consistency reasons for
consistency and alignment between uh the
various domains the various teams
because of course we don't want them to
recreate silos uh just in a different
way in a different format. We want to
break those silos. So we need
consistency and we need a certain level
of centralized control but we also want
to balance that with freedom for those
teams to develop solutions that are
really uh meeting their needs. Um so all
those conversations must happen. They
take time
uh and but they are necessary if you
want to uh gain trust and buy in from
your stakeholders.
A third challenge is uh training.
Uh IKEA is not a tech company. So we we
we're operating in a non- techch
environment.
Uh so we want to make sure that our
knowledge graph platform is user
friendly. And uh to to to make that
happen, we develop uh we have developed
uh intuitive interfaces for co-workers
to use. We're also um democ
democratizing ontology and taxonomy
design and development through tooling
again with intuitive uh interfaces that
don't require coding.
Uh we also have developed uh uh
comprehensive yet accessible training
materials and we offer um ongoing
support and uh uh upskilling
opportunities for for IKEA co-workers.
We're also working on developing uh
knowledge champions. That's people uh
within IKEA who are interested in
learning about ontologies and knowledge
graphs and want to upskill and uh so we
we offer them support and these people
can then serve as local experts in the
decentralized teams and uh and they're
also our advocates.
But it's worth it's worth worth saying
here that uh we haven't figured it it
all out yet. Obviously, we're learning
as we go along and we're constantly
adapting our approaches and our our
methods and uh and so it's it's a big
learning curve and it's it's it's not
over yet. But uh something positive I
can share with you is that um the
original team started with included
three uh subject matter experts. So IKEA
co-workers
uh who had all that expertise that we
wanted to translate into a knowledge
graph. they upscale. They learned about
knowledge graphs and and and and
reasoning capabilities and ontologies
and taxonomies and they on boarded on uh
a tool that we're using uh that is
making it possible for them to work
alongside ontologists and knowledge
engineers to to build the graph. Uh we
now have four uh of these subject matter
experts. We call them knowledge
modelers.
uh and uh they play a key role in uh in
building this graph
and and the good news is that now they
are training subject matter experts on
the decentralized teams. So that's
that's proof that people can be trained,
they can learn and there are things that
you can democratize. Uh and so you can
ensure that your your um your knowledge
the the your unique knowledge is is um
really comes from within the company
from your own experts.
Uh fourth challenge that we've uh met is
the gap between knowledge graph theory
and knowledge craft uh value business
value. So when we talk to uh uh semantic
experts and vendors, often the
conversations will gravitate towards uh
technical the technical capabilities of
of uh knowledge graphs uh and abstract
or um uh theoretical concepts.
But at IKEA, we're really focusing on uh
actual business value
uh business applications. So, how can we
use a knowledge graph to create better
experiences for both co-workers and and
and customers? So, there's a gap between
the promises everything you hear online
um on place platforms like LinkedIn for
this. It's quite a bit of a hype about
knowledge traps at the moment,
especially in the context of generative
AI. uh and everybody's interested in
building a graph, but
you will need to you will need time and
effort to actually identify
the the the business value of uh a
knowledge graph within the company. What
are you going to use it for? Um what
what problems is it going to solve? Um
so when we meet stakeholders uh within
IKEA uh Andreas uh and I uh we make sure
that we speak their language. We really
focus on their needs. We avoid talking
in theory about knowledge trusts and
ontologies. We avoid any jargon. we
really focus on what what problems
they're they're meeting, what they're
trying to achieve and then we try to
identify how a knowledge graph can help
them with that and what the what the
value is, what the business value of
that project would be. So that's
something to to really bear in mind if
you're interested in implementing
another trunk within your business is
that you know it doesn't come all out of
the box. You really have to put some
effort into identifying really what
you're going what you're going to do
with it. Um
so um
really underpinning all of these
challenges is uh is effective uh is the
importance the crucial importance of
effective stakeholder communication.
Uh we're trying to build trust uh uh
with our sharehold um stakeholders
through uh transparency on our processes
and on on our uh decision making. So uh
uh transparency is very important for
each decentralized team. Uh we really
work on identifying the business value
uh and and concrete use cases of our
graph.
We also have regular updates and uh
feedback sessions with our stakeholders
because we want to make sure that we
address real needs uh and real questions
or real concerns that they have. And by
adopting uh a collaborative approach to
development and innovation,
we're really ensuring that this new
technology is not perceived as a threat
by all of those teams. So the knowledge
graph and the AI is not going to replace
them. Uh instead, it's a tool. It's a
powerful tool that they're going to use
to innovate themselves and to u uh
streamline their own processes. We're
really hoping to uh uh foster a culture
of datadriven innovation across the IKEA
franchise ac across the IKEA value
chain.
So uh thank you for attending this
session for listening to my
presentation. These are contact details
if you have uh if you want to contact us
have any questions but I think I have a
bit of time.
>> Yes. Uh we have about three minutes and
then uh lunch. So, if we have a couple
questions, uh, we have one over there.
We've got people running around with
mics and I can get ready for the next
person.
>> Thank you for your talk. Could you tell
us a bit more about the tech stack? How
much is built in house? How much what
are the
>> about can you tell us a bit more about
your the tech stack under your knowledge
graph as a service what have you built
in house how much you're using some
vendors some details
>> we've got we've got the technical expert
here Rakkesh are you are you okay reply
I'm sorry
>> his best place to answer this
>> yeah so
Uh so the modeling uh as uh Crystal
mentioned the onlogy and the modeling is
mainly built by the knowledge experts
and once the knowledge not entrlogies
and the taxonomies are built uh we have
developed our own uh data transformation
uh in it's basically basically on a Java
built on a Java and it uses the
knowledge graph and ontologies and it
uses the JSON data of whatever your
product is and it converts it into a
triples.
Uh we used to use a Python model or a
Python package which was available
already in the market like open source
but it had some restrictions where it
couldn't uh map the nested uh datas of a
JSON uh structures. So we had a trouble.
So we had built our own like insourcing
uh uh application and once the triples
is um you know generated we do validate
it and then we uh import that into a
database or a data store and then we
create an API on top of it. So
technically the the stack is like you
get the ontologies you have your own uh
transformation or ATL models or
pipelines and you convert them into a
triples you validate them and then you
push it to your graph DB and then you
outsource it as as you need.
>> Yeah.
and and we also have reasoning rules um
that are actually developed with the
help of the uh uhmemes the subject
matter experts we call them knowledge
moders so all their expertise which is
in their heads um they can be
transformed into uh reasoning rules um
and they they use some tooling to uh to
do that
>> I saw you've got a question thanks okay
one more
>> okay yeah I had a question you mentioned
a tool for the um subject matter experts
to develop ontologies What are they
using?
>> Yeah, I knew someone would ask me that,
but I've been told I'm not allowed to
mention vendors.
>> No worries. Okay, no worries.
>> But there are many tools that uh
basically it's visualization. They draw
nodes and edges and that is then
converted into uh you know turtle or
whatever.
>> All right, everybody. I think we'll
probably leave it um for here. Please
find uh Crystal and the uh rest of the
IKEA team uh during networking and go
have a great lunch and back here at two.